yeah hi I'm Tom house you got my hair
talk about infrastructure as code with
terraform unless you're I'm just out of
interest who's using is your okay and
how you've heard of tariffs on before
cool is anyone using terraform cool yeah
so I've been working at how she called
for about two years but just coming out
two years working on these your provider
primarily how she caught maker suite of
products cool which I've focused on the
application lifecycle you may have heard
of a few of them they grunt pack a
terraform volt nomadic console this talk
specifically is about terraform tariffs
one is your but hopefully yeah hopefully
the principle should apply to any of the
other providers to terraform supporters
so just to get started what is
infrastructure as code infrastructure as
code is declaratively defining your
infrastructure in code in such a way
that you can apply standard software
development techniques to it so for
instance you can apply a code review and
continuous integration to your
infrastructure this also means you can
spin up in other regions as needed and
your infrastructure is documented and
also you can ensure it meets any policy
requirements so for instance if you only
need to be in specific regions or
specific instance sizes or whatever it
is yeah
there's also cloud specific yeah there's
also cloud specific versions of
infrastructure as code or yeah each
cloud offers its own kind of
provisioning system so for instance in
Azure that is an arm template Atos has
cloud formation Google has deployment
manager there's a whole bunch other so
yeah so what is obstructive escoba
terraform so terraform provides a dsl
that's known as HCl or the hash you call
configuration language which is kind of
JSON like so if we take a quick look at
some HCl this is two resources built
with HCl which creates a resource group
in a virtual network within as you
within this so in the resource group
name we define a couple of parameters
same thing for the virtual network and
we throat some variables through so in
this case we throw through the name of
the location from the resource group
back cool yeah so we thread through that
I'm in this example it means that you
can define things once so in the case of
is you you need to throw through a
resource group name into just about
every resource and also the location
field and a bunch of them and so rather
than typing like West US or Australia
self through every resource you can
reference it once at the top we'll come
back and break this down in a moment so
yeah so Excel provides a common language
which allows you to provision resources
using any provider across any provider
but that raises the question what do you
mean by provider so terraform supports
have an eighty officially support like
how she got supported providers and it's
possibly rain too there's about 80 plus
community providers I just want to call
out a few of them so terraform supports
clouds so the big names like anywhere
says your Google but also some smaller
ones like a scale way which yeah it's
also covers things like DNS so down a
simple powered in ass I'd also some path
services so you can like mix and match
these things which is quite nice it also
supports running stuff on premise
so as you're stuck in vSphere for any of
any existing infrastructure which means
you can mix and match Terra from how you
want well it's quite nice is because the
way telephone works if you have a crowd
API you can basically build a terraform
provider for it and so whilst what I'm
covering is is your specific today you
could plug anything together so if we go
back to the snippet we saw earlier this
is a smaller section of that if we break
this down a little bit the first one
here resource so terraform supports two
types of thing there's a resource and a
data source so a resource manages
something so in this case it provisions
a resource group and as you will come to
a data source in a bit
there's that a name of a resource so in
this case this is the name of the
terraform provider
so as URM and then this type of thing so
resource group virtual networks
something out whatever it is we then
have a friendly identifier for terraform
this is completely unrelated to your
code it's just an internal wrap it's an
internal reference so this could be main
this could be test this could be
whatever but you use this when you
reference resources from one another we
then have the properties within that
reservoir so in this case these are
required properties on a resource group
so the name of the location this emits
any optional ones but you can optionally
specify like tax or a resource group or
whatever they are bringing all this
together that this is kind of what a
resource group this is what a resource
looks like in terraform but how do we
actually provision that resource group
so terraform is come online application
so we can just run it download it and
run terraform and by default if you just
run terraform it's gonna show you what
commands or supports i want to call out
a few of them here so apply destroy in
it and plan which we're gonna go through
so Tara 4-minute is the first thing you
run and that basically looks at the code
that's on your on your in your current
directory and works out what providers
you were using so the in the case the
code i've said earlier we're using as
europe and so terraform is going to go
ahead and download these your binary is
your provider and download any modules
which again we'll come to in a bit
this basically prepares the working
directory
next up we have Tara from plan and what
this does is to work out the state of
the world so it looks at the
configurations you defined locally it
looks at the state of the world as you
and it goes does this resource group
exist and in this case the resource
group exists locally in the terraform
config but it doesn't exist in as you
and so Terrell wants to create that
resource group you can optionally output
this planter file as well so if you're
like running your account which may not
necessarily have admin rights to do this
you can save that plan that passed that
to someone who does next time is
terraform apply and so this will by
default will actually run terraform plan
and so you can pass in optionally
passing the pilot won't do this but
again it's gonna run a plan and go hey
here's what I want to do should I go and
make these changes
so what's terraform is doing that Tara
forms gonna output the progress of what
it's doing so in this case we're
provisioning a resource group which is
pretty quick like four seconds so it's
not gonna sit there and wait however for
longer operations it like when you're
studying a VM it's gonna sit there and
show what it's doing what's quite nice
is if you're using multiple resources
and and they can be performed in
parallel terraform knows for instance
that if you create a virtual network
with three subnets and knows it needs to
create the resource group first then the
virtual network but it can create the
three subnets of parallel and so
terraform can speed things up where it's
possible ok so as we've run Tara from
apply at this point if we rerun
terraform plan the state of the world in
Azure so the resource group will exist
and it exists locally which means
terraform will have nothing to do which
happens one thing of note is that
because when you do a terraform plan
terraform reaches out to as you or
whatever the provider is and goes does
this still exist if someone were to
manually make changes within as you or
manually delete the resource group in
this case terraform would detect that
and say hey i need to remove the tag or
i need to recreate it
yeah and then the final come on I wanted
to just call out is terraform destroy
this is really helpful so I know people
who are spending up in Tyre environments
like a humanities cluster at like 7:00
a.m. before everyone gets into the
office everyone does work for the day
and then it gets torn down at 7:00 p.m.
it's really handy like not having to log
into the portal or the CLI and like
render to delete things terraform can
work out the order of what needs to be
destroyed we're sorry again Tara forms
gonna give you a plan and yeah if you
enter yes if you say yes Tara home did
they do that
yeah sorry I wanted to give a demo of
this just goes yeah
so there's a repo for this that's on
github I will open source after this
talk can you will read that cool so um
so there's a couple of things here I
want to call out the first is this
provider block so we support there's a
version of Tara from core and there's a
version of a provider so in this case we
release them independently
so you can use any version of any
provider you want and a new version of
terraform you want in this case we
released 115 I think it was last week
but you can upgrade this out how you
want so in this case we create a
resource group with identifiers example
and in the Australia East region we
don't thread that through here with the
interpolation syntax so this is the
squiggly so and this is the name of the
resource so in this case the resource
group the name the identifier which as I
mentioned is terraform internal Oni and
then whatever property or access so in
this case name or location or whatever
else it is so we go to a terminal maybe
not that right now sorry this is the
file look we had open so yeah the first
thing we would do is to run terraforming
it and what that's going to do is say I
have we're using resources in these URM
provider which is the is your provider
and so terraform needs to go ahead and
download that so that's gonna go and do
that
maybe not cool okay that's really yeah
so the next thing we can run is to a
reform plan and what that's going to do
is to work out as I mentioned it's going
to query as you're and go hey ie locally
I should have a resource group and a
virtual network that exists does that
exist and so in this case they don't
yeah so in this case they don't so
terraform is gonna say I'm gonna do
these I'm gonna perform these actions
and so I'm going to create these two
resources you'll note down here it says
- to add to zero to change zero to
destroy we'll come to that in a minute
but terraform will show you what its
gonna create what it will destroy and
what properties change so if we run
terraform applying sorry everyone is new
Mac keyboards and like yeah sticky keys
go so again terraform is gonna say hey
here's what I think I should be doing is
that okay
well it's quite nice for this as you
could set this up on like a CI server to
go hey is like has anyone made any
manual changes yeah so cool that's gonna
go ahead and do that and as you can see
it's create the resource group first and
then the network terraform can infer the
ordering based on the config so by using
this interpolation syntax you're telling
terraform that this resource group needs
to exist first
so what's saying there's documentation
for all of this if you go to terraform
to i/o and there's a list of providers
and then is your and you end up on this
page which gives you example users
you've had to get started there's data
sources which we'll come to in a minute
but one of them that work
so if you scroll down on the left
terraform will give you example of the
the website gives you example usage of
how this works and those properties
listed as well so this kind of match
this mostly matches these your
documentation yeah so as you can see one
of the properties here is tags and so
because we've not specified any tags at
this point there are no tags on the
results but if we go ahead and add some
so and you see Sydney yep and rerun the
terraform plan terraform is going to
attack the these tags don't exist in as
your they do exist locally so terraform
is going to say hey we should have these
tags and what you're seeing here the
refreshing States is terraformed calling
out to as you ought to go hey like
what's the what's the latest state of
this resource so I mentioned earlier I
wrote one to change this is where
terraform will say I currently have no
tags on it there are there is one tag to
add and so I'm going to make that change
so if we were on terra firma ploy
that'll add those tags and we'll go back
to a good site
you
connection issues
it's a terraform that modifies that so
cool which means it's now in sync so if
we already rerun terraform plan
terraform will go there's nothing to do
which is nice so displays
so just to recap as for commands that
are kind of most important in terraform
which is terraforming it which downloads
the providers and basically sets that
sets the working directory up tariffs on
plan which determines what needs to be
applied Tara from apply which then makes
those changes and terraformed destroy
which was how things down you may not
necessarily want to run destroy all the
time but it's helpful to have it cool so
I hear you say Tara forms are willing
good but I have a ton of existing
resources with provision by the CLI
portal on templates whatever how can I
work with them in terraform so Tara form
has two means of doing this the first of
those is a data source and so I was a
resource earlier on was modelers
creating and modifying resource with
Tara form and managing it effectively a
data source is referencing information
about that so if you were to have for
instance a like a core networking team
who created a virtual network for you
and said your subnet is foo you can just
specify foo that you can manage it
however they want and you can basically
build decoupled systems this way or
decoupled infrastructure so in this case
it's very similar to creating a resource
so this is a data source the main
difference between a data source and a
resources web data from the word
resource yeah
one thing of know about data sources is
they expect the resource to exist and so
if it doesn't terraform will throw an
arrow and say hey they're really the
resource group existing network should
exist it doesn't so yeah
whereas a resource will create it so in
this example we just output a variable
so in this case the address space the
network the sided block yeah and as I
said you can build decoupled
configurations this way the other option
is importing so if you want if you have
this resource you provision through the
CLI or whatever else you can then bring
that to terraform and have tariff tariff
or manage changes coming for going
forward so the way you do this terraform
has another command so terraform import
the resource name an identifier and then
the actual is your resource ID and it's
your these are a bit long but in other
providers it's yeah yeah so again a
terraform import we'll go look that up
bring this into the state and you have
it locally but what's quite nice is each
resource on the terraform website says
how to import it and so in this work in
this case
sorry and so import functionalities is
opt-in but almost everything the usual
provider supports it there are a couple
of cases where there's no way of getting
the information once you've created it
like a service principle credential so
let's demo how to do that so in this
case
okay so in this case there's a virtual
network that exists called NEC network
resources or NDC shared network sorry
which is this one cool
I've rerun the terraform and in here
just because it's there's a couple of
these and takes a while so we run
terraform plan again what that's gonna
do is to look this up in Azure and go
hey this exists so I'm gonna create this
this summit for you eventually
cool but because this is just the
resource so to terraform alone you so
I'm going to create this one thing this
is just the subnet because we are
referencing the virtual networks or he
exists terraform I try and create it so
we can run the terraform apply here
that's then going to create the subnet
and yeah it'll leave the virtual network
as it is what's quite nice about this as
it means you can lock the permissions
down as well so you could say the user
who provisions terraform what that the
app ID the provisions terraform only hat
yeah provisions this thing only has
access to this resource group or they
social network or whatever it is
and just because it's good to confirm
these things will come so that works
sounds nice but if you take a better
example here so um
humanities is quite popular at the
moment but it mildly so a Cuban AG's
cluster takes a little while to spin up
and so you might have a long-running
Cuban eddie's cluster or up at the top
of the day or whatever it is with
terraform where I mentioned there's
multiple providers you can chain things
together and so in this case I'm looking
up an existing Cuban eddie's cluster
which is here and we're gonna use the
credentials from this to provision a
namespace in Cuba Dali's and the way we
do this is by sorry so I've run these
two commands locally just so we can show
the portal but the way we're gonna do
this is to thread the credentials from a
KS so terraform supports creating a tan
a KS cluster but it also exports the
kubernetes config so the hose the
password the secrets etc and so what we
can do is to say take the output of a KS
so their credentials and then thread
that 3d kubernetes
so that when I create the the namespace
it'll create NHS cluster which means you
can spin the whole thing up in one go if
you want or independently so in this
case if I run Tara from apply that's
going to go ahead and reach out to a
Kaos reach out as you'll get the AES
credentials
and then create the namespace in human
oddities
well it's quite nice as you can do this
with anything so you could take a DNS
record take your DNS from Azure and put
it into cloud flower or whatever you
want to do and if we refresh the
namespaces the namespace exists so you
get the same plan apply functionality
across any other providers which is
really nice and again if someone would
go and delete that you forget how you do
that and give a notice but yeah if
someone delete a tariff one would pick
up that it's gone and again I can run
Tara home destroy Tara forms gonna go
ahead and go hey this name say should no
longer exist so tear it down
so in this case yeah that says there's
one thing to destroy so this is because
we're using a data source the gas
cluster is going to leave it alone and
just destroy the namespace
well a nice things as well as you can
chain providers together so you can have
to as your providers one connected to
CIO subscription one connected to a
staging subscription if you wanted in
create virtual networks between them
that way yeah final thing I want to
cover was importing your IDs are it long
so I'm just gonna copy and paste that so
with importing I have an existing
there's a resource group that exists and
as you're called nuc madness NDC sydney
manual if you write the terraform
configuration for this right now
terraform thinks this doesn't exist so
one of the things i can do is to do
tariffs on import and then the name of
the resource in this case it is your RM
resource group dot the friendly
identifier which here is example and
then the resource ID
and so what terraform going to do again
is to look up the state of the resource
creep and as you're and to bring this in
locally which means that going forward
if I were to make changes to if we were
to add a tag
I'm running tariffs on plan so reform is
then gonna detect that it needs to have
that tagging I just already oh okay
so
um yeah as you've seen we can connect
any provider together so we can take
information from aks and put it into
even a DS or whatever combination we
want which is really handy the final
thing I want to cover was modules so if
you have all these terraform
configurations how do you stop yourself
like copy pasting them all over the
place so you can take so in terraformer
module is a directory full of TF files
so everything we've created thus far is
actually a terraform module it's just
not been referenced in that way and a
module can have inputs and outputs and
it can also come from multiple sources
so you could source it from a local file
system you could have a tariff or module
in a git repository or in a module
registry and as you're an example of
like the inputs and outputs would be the
resource group name because it's on
basically everything so in this example
we have the module coming for a local
file system so I have a folder called
modules and then example you can do the
same thing from a get tag so you can
create a git repo with teraphim files in
it and reference that internally and
there's the module registry - there's a
few of these so we have this thing
called the Tara for module registry
which is like a public source of
information a public source of Tara for
modules so if you want to find a
security group for a DBS or know how to
spin up a function up in Azure there's a
tariff or module for that there's also a
private motor registry which you can set
up internally for your own organization
and it's nuclei so let's document it
yeah so I just wanted to demo reasonable
reason code in a module so where are we
cool so this example is a little bit
bigger than the ones we've seen
previously so I have two modules here
factor of a few things to provide a
block as before we have a local block
which just does some interpolation for
us it's a different kind of variable we
carry a resource group and then it's two
modules there there's one for virtual
network and there's one for a virtual
machine and what we're gonna do is to
output the value of the admin username
of the public IP address from the
virtual machine so if we looked in in
these folders these are just regular
terraform modules as we had earlier they
have a couple of variables in them just
because it's convenient to do that so in
this case I pass a prefix sorry I should
explain so there's a you can define a
variable in terraform like this so
variable name you can optionally set a
type one as well it's like a map and I'd
default so if I wanted to do you know
everything has to have environment is
production or whatever I wanted to have
you can define that this way by having a
default variable it means these are
optional yeah so
these are just regular terraform
terraform resources as we had earlier
sorry
and this is going to create three
summits so a database of back-end and a
front-end subnet in the given resource
group in the given location and with
this prefix we then have the same thing
for the virtual network virtual machine
in fact that reminds me because this is
a virtual machine they take a little
while so I'm just gonna kick this off
while I'm explaining sorry should have
thought about
just explained us so where there's
telephone module terraform prefixes the
start of this identify with module name
so in this case if we come back to the
main TF we have a module with the name
of virtual machine this could be virtual
machine I don't know whatever or it
could be a collection of it could be a
modular cause other modules Tara four
modules are really focused so you can
basically do what you want with them so
you could build up like a module for
your API if you wanted or a module for a
server type of function Apple whatever
it is it sounds gonna go ahead and
create that we go to that do this thing
yeah the virtual machine module is very
similar so we define a public IP address
again using the prefix location as
before we then create a network
interface which has a public IP address
referenced above if we go to the virtual
machine this is just standard a buncee
machine with an OS disk and mices h key
because that's convenient
just to cool this out one I'm here the
terraform started splitting some
resources out so there are like a couple
of different ways of defining things you
can define data discs attachments inline
similar the way you can unlike an arm
template but you can also split them out
into separate resources so it's slightly
more readable so we have indeed a data
disc attachment so if you wanted to
attach your virtual disc to a virtual
machine as an example you could do that
like this which is yeah quite readable
so what I was going along hopefully that
starts shortly
well that's going ya terraform squirts
all kind of things in as you'll now I've
been on this for a couple years and
we've kind of gone from just the pack
just the infrastructure side to function
apps to of an Huck's to yeah I was
trying to do a talk earlier in the week
and yeah everything I need it was a
which was nice
sometimes they can take a walk
apparently but yeah when this machine
spins up what we're gonna do is just SSH
into a brief it works we could yeah
obviously change the prefix so everyone
in terraform will pick that up in the
same way it has before
but there's a module could also come
from the module registry if we wanted to
say it's the module registry is it
registry doc terraformed oh yeah that's
very blurry so if we search prettier in
here there's a bunch of examples
look about your machine as an example or
whatever it is you're after okay so we
have a virtual machine now so it has a
sage that cool and we have a machine
yeah exciting machine it does that's a
long time yeah so yeah tariffs or
modules you can as I said you can
specify them any price if you're doing
them if you're storing your tariffs or
modules in a git repository you could
apply semantic versioning to them I know
if you focus running tests with them as
well they have acceptance tests or their
tariff or modules they provide them
internally and then share them as they
need to just quite nice so just to
summarize the tariff forms DSL the
hashtag of configure a mesh has you call
configuration language allows for common
language to be used to provision any
infrastructure on just about any
provider terraform plan will show you
what change is going to meet your
infrastructure and then terraform
employee will make those changes
you can run planning cancel and you can
run apply in cancel out at any point
which is quite nice and when you're done
terraform destroy will tell that down
which is really handy for like cost
management tariffs on configurations can
also be shared in modules for code reuse
as I said there's a public module
registry that's a private one as well
yeah but you can write tariff or module
to do basically anything and also chain
providers together which is quite nice
cool
and with thanks any questions
hi
so but if I should repeat them so the
question is does terraform store in each
state and how does it manage that so by
default terraform stores that locally we
recommend you store that on s3 or on any
west blob storage sorry or there's a few
options for that so back ends there's a
bunch of documentation which are from
sorry about how to store that if we go
to so take this one as a simple example
and terraform store some information
about the results so knows what the
state of the world is yeah basically by
default it stores us locally you can
store this in a blob storage in s3 and
terraform enterprise in a bunch of other
providers or a bunch of other back-end
sorry so when you do an import basically
takes it retrieves the information from
you or whatever the provider is and then
it stores that locally if you use a back
end what terraform does is to store that
to put pull it from the blob storage
container or from s3 do the work locally
and then push it back
mm-hmm
sure so we don't that said there are
like specific command line flags in
terraform so sorry should repeat though
is there any way to paraphrasing is
there any way to get terraform running
in a CID so you see ICD pipeline without
user interaction yeah so what I do
terraform apply one of the options here
is waterproof which well yeah just
bypass the plan so if you wanted to do
that you could
there's downside so that if someone's
make changes and terraform I don't know
if someone's move the location and
terraformed says hey you can't do that
then terilyn will say i want to tell
that down and recreate it yeah
there are like this plugins with
different systems so like vs as your dev
ops has a plugin for that team city has
a plugin for it yeah at the end of it I
said come online binary so you can kind
of wrap it how you want there's no SDK
officially for it but there are come
online options for it hey so we use that
for state tracking sorry yeah so the
question was what what does the state do
what happens if you lose it so that is
for state tracking so at this point you
could import items back into the state
and tell from import so basically the
state is required because if something
is created and then as I mentioned there
are some resources which can be creative
and not necessarily imported so like an
access token
I think s3 is a good nice three some of
the iron stuff in aus is a good example
of this tariff when we uses that to keep
track of the state of world you could
pull this back together with terraform
import but yeah I mean this is how to
our contracts for infrastructure so did
that answer your question
any other
so if you just if you run tariffs on
plan or terraform apply without saving
the plan Terre Haute will recompute it
and go hey this this did exist it no
longer exists but now I want to recreate
it if you save the plan someone else
tinkers were there and then you try and
run apply with that plan terraform will
recompute the state of the world hey
this doesn't match and so like I'm just
gonna fail and say you have to rerun
plan because this is invalid that's kind
of why we run Terra Firma plight is why
you run the plan as part of apply now is
because it's I mean we're doing the look
up there so yeah sorry
so we don't have if a sari question is
the terraform sport conditional so we
don't have if-else we do have count so
an example resource group is a bad
example subnet would work give me a
second
so one of the things you can do
sorry subnets have Sider blocks and that
gets complicated so in this case one of
the options I can specify on a managed
disc or on any pro on any resource is
count so I can say create ten of these
and because I know because as your the
resource name needs to be unique you're
able to thread through through an
identifier so in this case I'm gonna do
NDC disc sorry Carol joined X which is
like a special variable for the
iteration it's running so if I run
telephone plan that's actually a really
good point
so terraform is gone and said there is
no you've referenced dr. excellent
you've referenced a resource group with
the identified test which didn't exist
and so terraform has like said this
doesn't work that doesn't comply it
effectively it's not compiling but it's
building a plan anyway semantics aside
so this is going to create I think it
was ten disks will suggest reading ten
disks you can you can set the count to
zero and that basically doesn't if else
or that basically will not create it and
you can have conditionals in there for
like if this is true in quotes make this
five otherwise make it a zero
so your variable example default so one
opens you can do in here then why since
I've done this so she five oh sorry in
much the same way as any other language
we've got coalescing to terraform
supports that
come
hi hmm oh yeah it's coming coming at
some point so we have some changes to
terraform syntax coming soon TM um so we
have a series of blog post on Tara forms
current version 0.7 and there's a next
version of terraform coming called sir
this next version of terraform 0:12
coming there's a bunch of blog posts
around this around some like changes to
the syntax counter module isn't one of
them but it is something we want to do
soon 0:12 would enable that you can
however pass another variable into the
module so call it number of instances
and then use that as the count if you
wanted to in turn on each results so you
can kind of hack around it it's just not
yeah anyone else
so yeah the question is if you try and
create if you have to instance the same
thing will terraform conflict
effectively right now yes in the next
release no there's a PR that fixes that
so specifically and as you're like if as
yours api's or upsets so at the moment
doesn't error we've realized that is not
optimal so we're fixing that it's worth
adding there's two ways of defining like
subnets specifically there's the
independent resource you've seen but you
can also define them inline within the
virtual network and if you do this this
will say only these three subnets can
exist and nothing else whereas if you
define them independently you can say I
only care about this one subnet I don't
care about the rest of them so if you're
if you want to guarantee that's the only
thing that exists you can do it this way
otherwise you can split it out there's
benefits to both it's whatever works for
you any other questions
yep terra firma prize gives you like
workflow for teams so specifically we
have something called policies code it's
called Sentinel policies code so you can
you can say you're only able to deploy
between 9 5 or you're only allowed these
instance types or whatever it is it's
basically workflow for teams grab me
afterwards we can chat it's on the
hashcode sighting alright yeah thanks